we all want to be looking and feline
good right i know i can't help it cat
puns
um i bet our writer chelsea white wrote
that she's a real cat lady
um it's not easy being so perfect yep
there's another one
okay why am i making oh so many cat puns
well this is what happens when you
improvise um
okay listen it's time to dive into the
history
of the cat eye and runways around the
world saw cat
eyes strutting down the catwalk to
accompany the hottest looks of 2020 and
2021. now
let's let the cat out of the bag here
right now
with this second in our series i love
these
beauty backgrounder
[Music]
let's claw back in time and discover
the history of the cat eye the cat eye
was first seen in ancient
egypt and the middle east where cold
cloaked eyes were believed to provide
a health boost and minimize glare from
the sun
a decorated eye was also said to protect
you from the
evil eye a curse transmitted through a
malicious and envious glare
cat eyes prowl throughout history on
high society women
and ancient rome in the 18th century
western japan
but the look really started to explode
when western countries
in the 1910s and 20s first began to
pillage artifacts
from ancient egypt and tut mania
inspired look from older eras in the 20s
cosmetics became more acceptable for use
by mainstream women
and flappers began to throw away rigid
prim looks
for something a little bit more stylish
in the 50s people went pawsitively wild
for a cat eye when liquid liner was
invented
and the starlets of the silver screen
started rocking the look
the 70s 80s and 90s saw the feline look
adapted for punks goths
grunge male stars such as david bowie
proved that a fierce look could be worn
by any gender
today the cat eye is still a ferocious
statement
and an instagram search of the term will
give you endless references
we love the cat eye because of its
versatility from
a subtle and classic application to a
subculture grunge look
you can live a whole nine lives with
different takes
on this feline tastic makeup trend